نحو واحد فاصله ثلاثه مليار دولار امريكي
فرضت كفراما على شركه متى الملكه لفيسبوك
وذلك كرقم قياسي يسجل بحق شركه تواصل
اجتماعي هذه الغرامه جاءت بعد نقل بيانات
مستخدمين في الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
الولايات المتحده ما عدا انتهاك ما عده
انتهاكا لحكم قضائي سابق يمنع ذلك على
الشركه اللجنه الايرلنديه لحمايه البيانات
قالت ان المجلس الاوروبي لحمايه البيانات
امرها بتحصيل هذه الغرامه الكبيره الا ان
مات اعلنت انها ستطعن في القرار
تحقق اللجنه الايرلنديه لحمايه البيانات
في نقل مثل الايرلنديه للبيانات الشخصيه
من الاتحاد الاوروبي الى الولايات المتحده
منذ عام
2020 ثلاث سنوات
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات